okay andy okay bryce repaying the favor
a little bit john mayer came and talked
to uh your walk of fame ceremony tonight
you're introducing him at his concert
has the walk of fame ceremony fully
settled in yet
you know it's starting to what's funny
now is two friends of mine went and
cleaned the star which was hilarious the
other day and sent me the video which i
posted and then today porsha texted me a
picture of her at the store so now i'm
loving that people are actually going to
the star which i never really thought
would happen uh the answer is no it has
not sunk in yet it's only been five or
six days and uh
i'm still in a form of levitation it was
a really great day uh made all
the more special by my family being
there my son and my parents it was it
was really great because of andy
everyone in america now has at least one
gay friend
it's a kind of advocacy that those in
need of a lesson intolerance don't even
realize is being taught to them the
biggest question i saw is wait when did
andy and john get so close what is the
story behind the bromance the story
behind the bromance gosh we met over 10
years ago through our friend ricky i ran
into them shopping
i didn't know much about john mayer at
all or his music
and i didn't i wasn't even so sure it
was him when we met and then we went out
onto bleecker street and there were
paparazzi and i turned to reiki i go is
this john mayer that we're with and he
said yes so there are actually photos
from the day that we met and that was
it was 10 years ago at least and we just
started there and became would see each
other around and he always had a great
spirit i would say the grateful dad got
us a lot closer because i was already a
major deadhead and then he started
getting into them and then imagine when
your friend starts playing with your
favorite band who you thought you would
never see again and now you can actually
tour with them so that was a big
kickstart to everything too kind of a
snowball effect there yes did you hear
from any of the housewives about their
name drops in john's speech for example
when homeland security shows up to the
beauty lab and laser parking lot and
your friend's life is suddenly in
shambles
will you be a heather gay or alisa
barlow
andy
is forever a heather gay
did lisa barlow call you up i didn't no
i didn't i think listen no matter what
he says if john mayer's you know calling
you out
i think it's pretty fun
it was all in good fun all in love all
right speaking of salt lake city we're
wrapping up season two but kind of
headed into a questionable territory
where does this show go from here
um how is the show gonna kind of handle
with reunion was filmed before these big
changes were made on the cast uh i think
you know what they're the truth of the
matter is
the
the reunion left off with the women that
are remaining
in quite a
dramatic spot where you don't know
what's gonna happen so i'm glad that
there are cameras on them right now
because it's already kicking off there's
a lot going on
and um i'm glad we're there shooting
right now i mean we did something
similar with beverly hills where we
started shooting uh this the new season
fairly soon after we shot the reunion
and in a case like both of those uh it
really paid off for the record mary
cosby is no longer going to be a
housewife on the real housewives of salt
lake city yes that is correct because
it's weird
it's like okay okay never mind
the jenny of it all i think the big
question is where's the line which i
think we're all figuring out what do you
say to that who people question well why
is she gone and others aren't listen i
think that this is a
we're in a time where we're producing a
show that is about outspoken
uh
sometimes politically incorrect people
who are speaking their mind
and
you know we have to be sensitive
to issues of racism
and
we have to look out for everybody who's
not only watching but who are also on
the show
and you know look there's every case is
different
but we want to do the right thing and
it's a work in progress i think that's
important it's case by case you got to
look at what the individual
concerns are ramona singer's name trends
every time something like this happens
how far away are we from learning what's
going on with new york
stay tuned
okay will ramona be back
stay tuned
jill dorinda
stay tuned i got no i got no news for
you i got nothing
yeah i've i'm asked that question all
the time but i i really have nothing to
say all right well switching coasts to
beverly hills
they're wrapping up their next season
can you say anything about what went
down in aspen lots of questions uh can i
say anything about what went on in aspen
i can't you're going to see it on the
show
yeah we will stay tuned um atlanta is
also wrapping up
their next season what's the cherry
whitfield three-peat looking like this
is her third time back i know i'm so
excited i'm i love cheray i'm a huge
cheray fan from the beginning
and uh
you know she's amazing and we're we're
about to wind down that season and i
don't want to give anything away but i'm
very excited about the finale that's
coming up all right they're neighbors
miami
having a kick-ass revival yeah how are
we feeling about a season five
um uh i feel bullish on it i feel
bullish on it it's a great season i'm
about to go back to my hotel and watch
part one of the reunion and uh it's
wonderful i think this was an amazing
rebirth for miami i love the ladies
there's so much drama there's so much
lifestyle they're beautiful they're
wealthy and uh dramatic and funny and
i'm thrilled about this reset
it's been a lot of fun to watch how
would you describe that reunion marisol
told me it was a very long day where she
had to pee a lot that's how she
described it she was yes she did the
reunion was you know what i loved about
the reunion they sorted through a lot of
their issues
uh there was a lot of drama but it was
there was not a lot of like
screaming
uh it was a pleasurable day for me i
really enjoyed it and i learned a lot
about all the women i loved it all right
and then oc having a nice little
renaissance too yeah how do you feel
though about kelly doddwang in every
week there's kind of this pipeline of
housewife to fire to podcasting about
housewives i love it i love it that you
know that a lot of the former housewives
are watching the show and commenting on
it and
you know listen it gets people talking
and good if she wants to watch the show
and comment on it more power to her
tamara judge also watching the show and
commenting i saw she's going to be on
watch it happens live soon what's the
over under of her coming back to oc one
day well i mean the what we're focusing
on is ultimate girls trip season two
which she's a part of and so that's what
i'm really looking at with tamara okay
also coming to watch what happens live
soon your girl sarah jessica yes will
you be pitching her the return of the
shoe salesman for in just like that
season two cute huh
oh yeah
okay
you know what she wouldn't be the one to
pitch it would be michael patrick king
and i wouldn't be so bold because
he has his own vision and
i i would never mess with his vision
it's perfect i could see you selling
some chuck taylors to che or something
that's funny all right it's super bowl
weekend here in la i know you feel a
certain type of way about the former st
louis rams so safe to bet on you are
rooting for the bengals i am rooting for
the bengals it's exciting i i'm i'm and
i'm rooting for the halftime show which
is really what i'm tuning in for
yeah that's the mary j blige show
[Music]
you